the final episode of the expanse is out
now amos rides a rocket through a sci-fi
kaleidoscope marco is eaten by
interdimensional aliens and drummer
becomes queen of space what does it all
mean what are the hidden easter eggs and
references and how does the final season
compare to the books season six is based
on the sixth expanse book babylon's
ashes but it also includes the story
from an expanse novella called strange
dogs so the episode starts on laconia
the planet ruled by juarte who led a
bunch of rogue martians here last season
juarte and the scientist cordesar
experiment with the proto-molecule
trying to control these mysterious
structures orbiting the planet
this girl kara is the daughter of some
scientists on laconia and she has
encountered some strange alien dogs the
dogs fix kara's broken drone they fix a
dead bird bringing it back to life as a
creepy zombie bird and now they fix
kara's dead brother zan
cause these dogs aren't ordinary natural
animals they are repair drones
technological constructs created by the
alien builders billions of years ago to
automatically fix things their faces are
described as looking embarrassed or
apologetic in the books and they like to
say
the aliens that created the dogs are
long extinct now but the dogs remain and
they still keep trying to fix things
even though they don't really understand
how a human is supposed to work so after
the dogs fix zan
san is different he feels weird and he
sees things that he couldn't see before
in glowing blue cgi
it's like what happened to katoa in
season three when he was changed by the
proto-molecule the dogs have changed zan
upgraded him with alien biotech
so is zan still fully human or is he
something else now kara is just happy
that she gets her brother back but when
she brings him home her parents gary and
dot are horrified they reject their
zombie son and attack him to kara's
horror because kara and her parents have
different world views they literally
grew up on different worlds gary and dot
are from earth where death is permanent
but kara grew up on laconia where death
can be fixed by alien dogs that's normal
to her like many real immigrant families
cara's parents have different rules and
expectations about the world than she
does and tragically this tears their
family apart cara tricks her parents
with a recording of her voice and runs
into the forest with zan she knows
she'll die out here without food or
water but says that the strange dogs
will fix her if she dies
so that's the end of the story for kara
and lil xan in the tv show but their
story continues in the expanse books the
expanse tv show only adapts the first
six books though there are three more
books beyond that hopefully the rest of
the story will be adapted one day
back in the sol system earth mars and
drummers belters plan their attack
against marco for most of the series
earth and mars were enemies and the belt
was exploited by the inner planets these
years of oppression and war have not
been forgotten it wasn't that long ago
that avasarala was hanging belters on
hooks but earth mars and the belt are
now forced to work together against the
greater threat of marco because if
marco's navy gets to medina station in
the ring space defended by laconian
railguns marco could solidify control
over all the ringgates dictator of a
thousand worlds
since duate gave marco a bunch of mars's
ships and earth's fleet was degraded by
years of pointless war their combined
forces might not be enough to stop marco
so plan b is for the rosie crew and a
ship called the gm batista to race for
the ring space and capture marco's
railguns before he gets there it's a
wildly dangerous desperate mission so of
course holden is totally optimistic that
it'll go great
bobby and holden take a moment to
remember alex who died last season alex
was kind of the social glue that held
the rosie crew together his friendly
easygoing personality balanced out the
extreme personalities of holden naomi
and amos while the rest of the crew
battled aliens and saved the universe
alex often stayed on the ship and looked
after their home he made sure everyone
was eating and was cared for he was like
a parent so when alex died and clarissa
and bobby joined the crew the whole
dynamic of their family was disrupted
and the crew almost broke apart
amos almost quit after holden spared
philip holden was uncomfortable with
clarissa who did try to kill him a few
times and naomi didn't like amos and
clarissa's friendship cause it used to
be amos and naomi who had a special
close relationship in season one they
were both damaged vulnerable people so
they survived by supporting each other
amos protected naomi and naomi guided
amos he called her his boss
but now amos has grown up and become a
leader himself he guides clarissa and
she calls him boss like he once called
naomi so naomi comes to understand and
accept this relationship and welcomes
clarissa as a member of the family
but clarissa is dying cause back in
season 3 she tried to kill holden as
revenge for the downfall of her father
jule pierre clarissa got illegal biotech
mods implanted into her body that can
enhance her strength and speed for short
bursts but these mods are not fda
approved they constantly leech hormones
into her body damaging her health and
now she learns that she's only got about
five years to live
the screen says that salt craving is one
of the symptoms of her condition which
explains why she ate so much salt a
couple episodes back clarissa knows that
her time is running out and she chooses
to spend her last years with her new
family she cooks a proper meal for them
all like alex used to do
in book six naomi thinks that she
treasures her time with her loved ones
because she knows it won't last forever
everything ends and that's what makes
these moments precious
drummer prepares for battle with marco
the man who killed her friend ashford
killed her friend fred and killed her
partner serge the man who started the
war that broke her family apart
drummer flies ashford's ship the tynan
into battle and she's convinced a belt a
leader called walker to join her side
in the book there's a whole plot line
about holden trying to convince a
diverse bunch of belter opa leaders to
work with earth and mars against marco
fred johnson had been the best hope to
unite the opa in cooperation with the
inners but fred suddenly dies in book
six so it's only with the help of doors
that holden's able to bring the belters
together
drummer and her allies attack marco but
marco pulls a sneaky trick by disguising
his ship the pella as a different ship
it's kind of like how the rosie was once
disguised as a harmless gas freighter
marco counter-attacks and cripples
drummer's ship ending her chance for
revenge
drummer had to swallow her pride to join
earth and mars against marco she left
her family behind to fight this war but
now she just suffers more defeat she
feels that she's lost everything that
this universe has no place for her so in
rage and despair drummer tries a suicide
attack on marco but walker beats her to
it is there a place for drummer in this
universe
in the book drummer's plotline is taken
by a similar character called michio
parr in her battle with marco parr is
badly burned and is forced to recover in
a makeshift hospital in a luxury resort
on titan it's a strange surreal scene in
limbo between life and death parr
grapples with all that she's lost before
rising reborn and finding new purpose
so while drummer earth and mars distract
marco the rosie and the gm batista get
to the ring space bobby and amos are in
the assault team attacking the ring
station to take the railguns we see this
list of the other soldiers on the
assault team and most of these names are
references to famous sci-fi stories
ripley vasquez hicks and hudson are
characters from the alien movies the
creators of the expanse have said that
alien was a huge influence on the
expanse specifically in how it portrayed
average people with blue-collar jobs in
space like the crew of the cant in
season one we also see the names of
admiral akbar from star wars david
bowman from 2001 a space odyssey
commander shepard from mass effect
duncan idaho from dune rick deckard from
blade runner jack o'neill from stargate
johnny rico from starship troopers sarah
connor from terminator and will riker
from star trek so these are some of the
greatest badasses in sci-fi history and
bobby draper and amos burton are right
there with them
there are more easter eggs in these
names comment below if you spot one the
gm batista dumps lots of empty
containers as decoys to provide cover
for the assault team as they drop onto
the ring station one of the containers
has the logo of mao kwakowski mercantile
which was the company of jul pierre mao
before he was imprisoned for his
protomolecule conspiracy the mao part of
the mao quick logo has been scrubbed off
giupia's daughter clarissa struggles
with her father's legacy as we see in a
bonus scene for this season there are
five bonus scenes in season six and you
can watch them on amazon prime video on
a phone pc or fire tv by clicking x-ray
in the top left then bonus content the
episode 4 bonus scene follows clarissa
as she finds out that her father jupiter
has died in jail she hates that she
always wanted the approval of such a
terrible dad so much of the evil she did
in season three was to try and win his
love but now clarissa's found a better
family with amos and the rosie crew at
the end of the scene she starts to clean
up a mess she made she likes fixing
things now because that represents
making up for her mistakes so she
continues to fix things in the finale
heroically risking her life to repair
the rosie mid-battle
meanwhile the assault team land on the
ring station amos survives a sci-fi high
g [ __ ] while bobby makes a more
dignified entrance but the assault goes
badly and many of the team are killed
r.i.p hudson game over man it's game
over in the book the soldiers defending
the ring station are duate's rogue
martians helping marco so bobby loves
the opportunity to get some revenge
against the martian traitors who
betrayed her homeworld bobby goes all
iron man and defeats the enemy but is
forced to destroy the railguns with a
missile which was not the plan they had
hoped to capture the railguns so they
could use them against medina and
against marco when he arrives but bobby
had no other choice in the book it's a
bit different bobby tries to capture the
railguns by just blowing up their power
source but the explosion causes a
reaction from the ring station itself
the entire station turns green and it
physically expands to break the railguns
it's like how it reacted to an explosion
in season three bobby's attack seems to
make the station angry
so this is a reminder that the ring
space is a remnant of a vast and
mysterious alien empire and humanity is
messing with powerful forces that they
do not understand
but either way the railguns are broken
leaving the roci alone and defenseless
with all the power of marco's free navy
burning hard to destroy them
but on the way to the ring marco gets a
message from juarte on laconia duate is
an important ally for marco because
dratic gave him his ships and his
railguns and marco hinted earlier that
he's expecting something more from
juarte soon maybe some secret weapon or
reinforcements or something but now
duate tells marco to get [ __ ] he's on
his own laconia won't help marco anymore
because all along duate was using marco
he only gave marco ships and weapons so
that he'd keep earth and mars busy so
that duate could settle on laconia
undisturbed having marco in the ring
space was a useful buffer so that to get
to laconia people would have to get
through marco first joate's tone is kind
of mean and sarcastic here he enjoys
disrespecting marco but in the book
joate comes off as more respectful and
sincere joate really believes that he's
doing what's best for humanity and
that's part of what makes him so
dangerous duarte says that he has gods
to kill because juarte's mission is to
defeat the mysterious entities in the
ring gates juarte is building a great
laconian empire empowered by alien
technology to save humanity from this
interdimensional threat
so duate and laconia have a really cool
plotline which continues in the next
three expanse books
juarte's rejection is a huge loss to
marco but when philip turns up marco
hides his rage and acts like
everything's going great marco
constantly lies and bullshits everyone
around him he said himself that he tells
people whatever they need to hear the
books emphasize how whenever he fails at
something marco acts like that was
actually his plan all along marco
manipulates everyone including his son
so this season philip questions his
loyalty to marco philip feels guilt for
helping marco kill billions of people on
earth and guilt for killing his friend
johan out of stupid misdirected rage he
meets this guy tedeo and learns that
tadeo had a brother who was killed by
marco's bombs on ceres
last season naomi told philip that marco
made him a murderer and that one day
philip will feel guilt for his crimes
now that day has come
philip is shaken by the death of
rosenfeld and tells marco that it could
have been philip who died but marco
doesn't care and says he'd be proud if
philip died for the cause
last season naomi told philip that marco
would let philip die for him but marco
wouldn't die for philip and now philip
says that she was right
marco gives a big speech about how his
revolution will free the belter people
but philip now sees that's not true
marco abandoned millions of belters on
ceres marco doesn't listen to sandrani's
plans to feed the belt he's more
interested in his personal vendettas
against drama holden and naomi marco's
revolution only really serves himself
and philip finally sees that his father
is nothing more than a selfish
manipulative murderer
last season naomi told philip that
sometimes the only choice is to walk
away and so now philip walks away he
leaves marco on his own ship and finally
escapes his controlling father he
rejects the inaros name and instead
names himself philip nagata after his
mother
naomi never finds out that philip
escaped marco but her words free her son
the rosie crew stand alone in the ring
space apparently sarah connor and duncan
idaho didn't make it they're outnumbered
and outgunned by marco's free navy so
they prepare for a heroic last stand but
then naomi comes up with a plan to wake
the mysterious alien entities these
entities have been destroying ships that
go through the ring like the barqueth
last season naomi and the scientist elvi
figured out that these entities become
active after a certain amount of mass
and energy goes through the ring so just
as marco arrives the rosie crew throw
the gm batista through a ring to
activate the entities and so marco is
obliterated along with his navy
it's kind of like gollum dying amidst
orange cgi at his moment of victory in
lord of the rings there's even a ring
in the books when the entities kill
people people experience changes to
their perception and consciousness in
marco's last moments he stops seeing
objects and instead sees the molecules
those objects are made of and the
photons bouncing off them instead of
hearing sound he perceives the
vibrations in the air his sense of self
melts into a cloud of energy before the
entities slither through the nothingness
and sweep him to oblivion the entities
manipulate consciousness itself as a
weapon and these ideas are explored more
in the last few expanse books
so the rosi crew kill marco and finally
end this war the horror for naomi is
that she believes she has killed her son
philip never knowing that philip
actually left marco and survived
inspired by her words
later naomi says that all we can do is
try to help others it doesn't matter if
we ever know that we made a difference
it's not about making ourselves feel
good but the right kind word might
change someone's life so it's always
worth trying
there's a big meeting with the leaders
of earth mars and the belt to figure out
the architecture by which we try to
unfuck ourselves as avasarala says in
the books
she says war doesn't end on the
battlefield war ends at the negotiating
table because killing marco was the easy
part the hard part is making a peace
that will last
unless they can build a more fair and
stable political order they'll just end
up with more war in the future as
drummer said extremists like marco are
inevitable in a system that is unjust
and unequal for belters
the big problem especially in the book
is that the belt doesn't have a future
the whole reason why belters exist was
originally to mine resources in the
asteroid belt over the generations their
culture and bodies adapted to life in
low gravity but now through the ring
gates there are thousands of new
habitable planets with free air and
water where it's way easier to get
resources these new worlds are the
future of humanity but belters have no
place in this future because most
belters like naomi can't survive on
planets with gravity because their
bodies are adapted to space and those
belters who can live on planets within a
few generations won't be belters anymore
the belters as a people and a culture
face extinction
marco's solution to this problem was to
block off the ring gates so that earth
and mars would still need the belt he
wanted to preserve the status quo just
with belters in charge instead of the
inner planets but now the leaders of
earth mars and the belt find a better
solution looking to the future instead
of to the past they form a transport
union to govern the shipping and trade
between the ringgates it's really
important to have someone coordinating
ring transits because otherwise people
might accidentally get eaten by the
entities and there needs to be a lot of
trade right now because since marco
broke earth and was blocking off the
ring gates the colony worlds and damaged
earth are desperate for each other's
resources plus many people want to leave
earth and mars to settle the new worlds
so there's a lot of work to be done
coordinating transport and trade in
space and belters are the best people to
do it the belter's new hope for an
economic and political future is to
become galactic shipping magnates
in the book holden jokes that they
should call the union the spacing guild
which is a reference to a similar thing
in dune
so everyone agrees that a transport
union is a good idea but they can't
agree on who should be in charge of it
after a century of conflict the inner
planets and the belters don't trust each
other avasarala suggests that holden
should be in charge because he has
worked with earth's martians and belters
fairly he has experience with ring space
from medina station and you know he's
the protagonist and he's very handsome
so of course he should be in charge
holden agrees to be the first president
of the transport union the brave warrior
protagonist becomes king in the end like
aragorn in lord of the rings or the
bloody povenzi kids but in an unexpected
twist holden immediately steps down and
makes drummer the new president instead
he says that if the transport union is
the future for belters it should be led
by a belter and drummer is more
qualified for this than holden she has
experience running medina station in the
ring space she was medina's captain back
when it was the behemoth drummer did
shipping and distribution work bringing
supplies to series which is the sort of
thing the transport union will do
drummer has proven her commitment to the
belt over and over and she's shown a
willingness to cooperate with earth and
mars
drama was always the quintessential
belter and after six seasons of struggle
she brings hope for her people
it's also a great character moment for
holden to pull off this sneaky trick he
pretended to agree to be president under
certain conditions plotting all along to
give it to drummer cause holden's whole
thing in the beginning of the series was
to be honest and open about everything
he thought he knew what was best for
everyone he made the decisions and he
told everyone his true intentions but
this time he hides his true intentions
and gives the power to choose to someone
else it shows how much holden has
changed and grown from the naive
idealist he once was
people like miller and avasarala taught
holden that sometimes you've got to lie
for the greater good naomi and drummer
showed holden that he needs to share
leadership with others he is not
personally responsible for running the
universe saving humanity is a group
project
clarissa gives amos a badge of a devil
face amos used to wear one like this but
apparently he lost it last season
clarissa now replaces it and makes one
for herself as a super adorable symbol
of their friendship though the badge has
a dark backstory
in the expanse origins comic book we see
amos and his friend saru when they were
sexually exploited as children saru
committed suicide but he gave amos his
devil badge telling amos to live and to
keep smiling
so the devil badge represents amos
hiding his trauma behind a mask being
emotionally detached to survive
but over six seasons amos grows and uses
his experience of trauma to help others
transforming a symbol of pain into one
of connection and hope
at the end of the expanse holden says we
still don't know what's going on with
the proto-molecule and laconia and
juarte at the end of the credits we see
the entities still lurking in the ring
the expanse tv show is ending without
finishing the story from the last three
expanse books
but the creators of the expanse say that
they're just pausing the story and that
the last three books might be adapted
someday
holden is eager to face this future but
naomi says let's just stay and enjoy the
moment in the present as the rosie sails
the vast expanse
the expanse is about spaceships and
aliens and explosions and it's really
about the tragedy of human conflict no
matter how far we expand into the
universe our politics and our tribes
divide us
heroes are those who try to unite us at
the end of the expanse everything has
changed humanity has expanded from just
one solar system to new worlds across a
thousand stars
earth is devastated mars is obsolete the
belt is transformed but all the old
divisions remain this isn't the end of
war
so everything's changed and nothing's
changed really
at the end of book six anna and her
family head for a new life on a new
world she thinks no matter how far
humanity expands we're basically stuck
with each other we're spending our lives
together in this universe and all we can
do is try to get along
if we're gentle maybe the stars will be
better off with us
thanks for watching and thanks to amazon
prime video uk for sponsoring this video
you can check out the bonus scenes for
season 6 on amazon prime video by
clicking on xray then bonus features
please like and comment and subscribe to
this channel and to alt shift x
cheers
you